if let's say you disagreed with me you'd  say why and uh if it made sense we'd  like air our differences publicly on on  the substance of it like what happens  when Tony Sachi does this is a sense  you're absolutely right just sends a  signal to all the other scientists in  biomedicine that if you step out of line  you know if attorney says I am the  science you know if you disagree with me  you're disagreeing with science itself  if you step out of line your career is  at stake you don't you don't want every  chronic idea but this was not a crank  idea these were prominent people in  respected institutions stay saying look  this is this policy is wrong